Suicide Squad is the latest in the DC
Comics film universe where a team of the
world's most dangerous incarcerated
supervillains with nothing to lose are
sent on a top-secret government mission
to defeat in ignem attic insuperable
entity will the Suicide Squad resolve
their differences and die trying or
decide it's every man and woman for
themselves i'm edmund tran and joining
me is just mcdonald and luke lancaster
from cnet hey guys is also written a
bunch of film reviews for us so just a
forewarning this discussion of suicide
squad will contain mild spoilers so if
you want to go and cold stop watching I
mean you can also return in Guerra's
review on gamespot instead but guys did
this film give you the warm fuzzies
squad goals feelings or did it make you
want to kill yourself I'm gonna go with
a ladder yeah a little bit oh yeah
that's harsh exaggerating I think it's a
little bit exaggerated yeah I didn't
want to kill myself walking out of the
movie it wasn't good point it is a
relevant sentiment that I think a lot of
us felt yeah I disappointed a good way
gently walked out of it not loving it
now before we go further let's quickly
disclose our familiarity with the source
material I've since audience mileage
tends to vary with this kind of film so
I'm a big marvel fan I've never been
able to really get to DC heroes very
much despite trying with comics and film
so I'm not entirely invested in Suicide
Squad I'm coming to these characters
mostly fresh I'm pretty familiar with
all of them again or more of a marvel
man which I feel like will be held
against me for not liking this movie um
but I certainly didn't I certainly
wasn't unfamiliar with anyone going into
this like I knew the general Suicide
Squad concept on your wall the
characters you could kind of pic where
the plot was going but that's a
different thing yeah I'm definitely the
far side on the other direction past you
guys I had not heard of Suicide Squad
before the trailers for this movie came
out I knew Joker and Harley but that's
about it now we're going to go through a
bunch of the characters shortly but
first of all let's talk about the plot
the plot of Suicide Squad that brings
everyone together the setup and the
adventure that follows so basically the
threat I mean we should talk about the
threat right because we going straight
back oh yeah the reason Suicide Squad is
basically put into action
is yet to deal with superhuman threats
we need super humans and that threat
happens to be Enchantress has brought
about her brother back to life so
enchantress is a witch who's possessing
an archaeology an archaeologist whose
boyfriend is working for the government
as a soldier who has the most military
name at the great Rick Flagg Rick Flagg
is right the caretaker of the Suicide
Squad or something yeah yeah yeah it's
never really made clear yeah i mean
that's who he is but he's just kind of
there as the official on the ground
managing all the crazies equivalents yes
so what do you guys think about how that
was brought together how they got even
out of jail and put them it was both
really rushed and took way too long you
know yeah so basically what we got at
the start of the film was like little
profiles on each character so obviously
the squad's a lot of people and a lot of
people that people probably aren't
familiar with unlike perhaps model um so
basically what they did was give you
sort of backstory and show you how they
were caught and it kind of felt like
here's why you should care about the
characters but didn't really give
compelling reasons to do so yeah of the
squad which was I think close to 10
people the only two of them that were
really well developed was dead shot it
was Will Smith and Harley Quinn margot
robbie yeah but those are like the two
most famous members of the squad in
terms of character anyway yeah
absolutely um but even then it was all
kind of loosely connected flashbacks to
stuff yeah and that was the only real
character moment you got for anyone yeah
yeah it's quite telling that the film
started on the character moments yes
yeah but when they eventually got to the
main sort of mission there the stakes
weren't there for that I didn't really
care whether the city would be torn
apart well not even that it's these
characters are on a do-or-die mission
and you don't particularly care if
they're going to die no I mean that's
that's not what you want right yeah
that's true well let's go into the
portrayal of characters actually let's
start let's go one by one let's go with
Holly first yeah what do we think of
Holly think of us some problems what I
thought was a shame is they do actually
use um quite a lot from her story her
origin story where you
she's got quite a mention already met
with Joker she's initially his
psychiatrist in Arkham Asylum he
convinces her to break him out and then
push it no what convinces he actually
convinces her to get into a vat of you
know see me by the companion I quit um
and it's sort of the romance
underpinning the film which anyone who
understands the story of Holly and joko
which is basically quiet of course a
moment is a strong word but I felt like
Suicide Squad pumped it up as a romance
like that'll be like trying to save her
and he's he's like Joker doesn't come up
too much but he's on her radar he's
trying to find her she's obviously not
really a damsel but there is you know
quite a lot it seems like there's quite
a lot of love between them which is an
odd thing to be delivering a lot of
scenes of them coming back to get that a
lot flashback scenes of like him
protecting her from other people like
yeah I kind of stuff and lots of scenes
of them dancing in flashbacks which is I
mean I think that's really at odds with
especially a lot of modern Harley Quinn
comics where there is very much that
abusive relationship in her past but
it's a real character note for her
moving beyond that now and i know this
is only the first movies first time she
was on screen so you don't really have a
lot of room to tease that out but she
never really got the moment where it's
like hang on this is not a good
relationship no um and you don't see her
kind of built up apart from the Joker
yeah that's correct yeah I think I'd
felt like kind of a sheller betrayal I
mean I don't think it's really mugger
Robbie's fault but it just felt like she
was quite basic like I'm when she did
have feelings it was oh I'm not just
like you know sexy and cute i'm actually
upset that my boyfriend's gone and stuff
like that but she's still trying to play
it cool and that was as deep as she got
like as far as I saw that was as complex
as she got just speaking of things that
were Margo Robbie's fault her accent was
so ani it did come off in the beginning
she started since is very strong and
went to the sort of Brooklyn accent
supposed to be yes but how did you think
that the kind of performance otherwise
was okay like well how about the crate
little crazy coming through and little
quips and like kind of stuff I think I
was meant to find her a lot funnier than
idea yeah and I think anyone who's even
just seen the trailers can probably
vouch for the fact that a lot of the
lines that are given to Harley Quinn are
supposed to be oh she's so cute she's so
nuts but they just fall flat and I think
that's on the writing it's just like the
moments didn't weren't punchy as well
like her one-liners weren't delivered at
times and it made any sense for her to
be saying something cute and quirky so
most the time she opened her mouth it
was a little cringy yeah which is
unfortunate because she should be cooler
than that yeah yeah I had a very hard
time believing that she could feasibly
beat the [ __ ] out of all those sort of
enemies yeah there was no sort of she
knew I just spin that skill yeah I'm so
annoyed that she had the baseball bat
like she had the mallet in her hand
that's why I never usually it is there
then she went there was some classic
costume yeah like yeah cameos and that
kind of stuff to this movie does that a
few times do I think it's a problem
where it will have an allusion to
something that's really cool or it will
make a little joke and then completely
ignore in the next scene is sweet on you
guys yesterday there's a part in the
movie where the Suicide Squad decides to
basically disband and they find out oh
you can you make it they might be able
to get away from their predicament and
not have to you know go with the
government anymore and the Australian
guy boomerang is like sweet I'm out of
here and bolts and it's funny and then
in the very next scene he's with the
gang again not not only that he's back
in the very next scene his name is
Captain Boomerang and literally no one
comments on the fact he leaves and comes
back with no explanation that is the
biggest missed opportunity in the
history of filmmaking huge it just felt
like they kept wanting to do cute things
and the same problem comes up in all the
the classic songs that they keep
throwing in mmm we got the Queen banging
wraps it pretty much everything they
used in the trailers yes but they're
peppered they aren't there two guardians
of the galaxy style punctuate fun
moments it's more just like remember
this are you having fun if you're
talking about the Guardian soundtrack
there was a totally diegetic reason
every song slightly that was star-lords
tie to earth it was that one mixtape
yeah and so every time one of the songs
came on you could feel his connection to
it this was just looking fro in some
songs because people like these songs
late mishmash of genre yeah like style
and they really just hammered at home
every single time the same would start
with the song and it will just punctuate
the whole scene amusing media style yes
you know it kind of is like they're
going forward through the surrounding
artwork and start kind of like the
dayglo neon aesthetic and the music
video style like it did feel like that
it felt very music video the whole way
through absolutely but yeah they really
just like wanted to hit you over the
head with that kind of stuff which
whereas God instead much more subtly
moving on to the older characters there
let's talk about Deadshot yeah was I
like to call him dad shot dead because
he from my understanding of dead shot as
a character he's a real hardcore hitman
he has very few merchants and he's just
really freaking good at his job I mean
that's that's pretty in keeping with
most portrayal of Deadshot's have you
watched the young arrow and flash I have
noticed well he's in that as well but
he's much more in keeping with that he's
just a good shooter guy so I haven't I
don't know anything about Deadshot I did
not see Deadshot what I saw was Will
Smith he's missing everything no he was
a dad he cared about his kids much likes
Will Smith does yeah and um he seemed
like a really good guy it was hard to
remember the dead shot was a bad guy
this is the pursuit of happiness with
guns Fox quite but yes there was a lot
so he was probably one of the characters
had the most sort of character
motivation he was always looking out for
his daughter and like looking after what
was best for her yeah I mean going out
of his way to sort of go against what
may or may not have been his morals as a
hit man to protect her yeah really can I
just say just in terms of like character
motivations and poor trails in this
Batman makes a few cameos like you've
seen him in the trailers yes um he's
kind of a dick Batman's kind of a Batman
is kind of a dick like Catholic it's the
is at the very first scene with Deadshot
and Batman yeah where he arrests dead
shot in front of Deadshot's little girl
so dead sure doesn't make a scene yeah
and then later on he like saves Harley
from drowning and
punches her in the face like Batman big
dick oh well yeah shushes / she did but
like which was a good scene come on
Bruce Batman was kind of like one of the
highlights of the film for me because
like I could understand that perhaps
this was bath lake as seen from the
village true and he's just a huge scary
bad ass who just yeah no [ __ ] I kind of
would have liked more of him yeah in the
movie it was nice having him as a
footnote particularly since the start of
the film focused on how they were all
captured and the fact that so many of
them were captured by Batman just made
sense there was one of the cool things I
felt like this film kept getting really
close to doing cool things and having
cool moments it just wasn't underpinned
by anything cohesive or well paid they
didn't flush out the moments they didn't
like Kaname annum I mean he said manner
on a personal note I am really annoyed
that that is the first time I've seen
the live action flash properly in the DC
Cinematic Universe and it was just so
underwhelming I don't get the chair not
a fan of his costume either no it's like
a weird kind of helmet mm-hmm I don't
know he doesn't need that stuff he runs
around real fast and his pants should be
made out of going fast that's what he
does um jogo talk about Jared Leto like
yeah I am not sure why he was in the
movie apart from giving the the movie
some romance cuz otherwise he'd had none
and you know that's just a hold of a
plastic leg and generous like the
central romance underpinning the entire
block mostly not I know right yeah
that's true that's true generally by
that love either yeah but Joker seemed
to be hot birth Holly's motivation as
well as a plot disruptor i can comment
and just sort of paint more obstacles
for the team to sort of recover from
yeah he wasn't in it very much he did
feel very tacked on he felt kind of just
we need to joe christmas movie they
could have had the same movie without
the Joker and not that i think jared
leto did a bad job i actually quite
enjoyed his betrayal I thought it was
kind of good I just wish he was a little
more embedded in the story instead of
sort of an afterthought and holly's
boyfriend and again like they touched on
a lot of iconic Joker moments like
dancing with Harley when he's in there
kind of dinner jacket and white tuxedo
yeah yeah they're over all vanam jared
leto as Joker I didn't see nothing to
like say one way or another I had a few
like psycho moments yeah they had a few
moments where he did really remind me of
Ledger's Joker Ledger's Joker mind blank
there that's do you think you'd want to
see more of letter as Joker I would like
that I i mean yeah i mean i'd like to
see more just to form an opinion yeah
yeah well he must be the focus everyone
was so down on him when he was first
revealed yeah and I can I can see why
and I think the people who were down on
him will see a lot more of what they
didn't like in him yeah he's pretty much
what you expect I don't think he was
particularly surprising yeah absolutely
yeah i never i will say i never found
him threatening in the way that I
thought Heath Ledger's Joker was
trending right yeah no definitely but he
was never menacing he was just there all
right let's go through the rest of the
squad very quickly because you know they
did not get a lot of get a lot of time
we'll go through it quickly just like
the movie day yes that's right ok Killer
Croc should have been King Chuck cuz
you're being King shot yeah he was just
kind of the big tough guy who didn't
want to speak real much he just scaled a
bunch of people and kind of saved the
day here once or twice yeah
unfortunately I think he had maybe two
lines in the home yeah I really think he
did yeah he spent most of it just
sitting in account I do love the plot
and by love i mean i hate the plot
contrivance where he's the swimming dude
so they needed to be an underwater bit
in the final battle scene so he has
something to do it was it a little bit
subtle but even then they didn't have a
big moment they're not show off his ego
I think that was quite a common theme
with a lot of the heroes that you know
big flash mem to be like this is why I'm
so valuable to my memory I don't think
Captain Boomerang throws a boomerang
apart from that first scene in wash back
it was really to be there you know he
was there for like unicorn jokes yeah
one-liners I think you were saying
earlier that Captain Boomerang and
Deadshot are essentially the same kind
of except one uses boomerang is that one
news yeah um I really liked ya blue I
thought yeah I guess he was the only one
with
story as well he had a really hot sorry
just on Captain Boomerang yeah can we
talk about how his backstory is he
robbed literally every bank in Australia
that's what they say word for word which
as a straight came over to the United
States and as anybody is a very strange
you are aware of how many banks there
are in just a regular city let alone a
country yeah I mean good for him though
yeah yeah no no with the dust bus like
to be honest like I I probably lean
towards him as one of my favorite yes
suicide cause at least he leaned into
the ridiculousness that's right yeah he
should have been some kind of agreement
as to whether we were going silly are we
taking you seriously not because it felt
like people were on different pages i
don't think the director writer all
actors were on same page tell diabla
yeah well diabla was [ __ ] suede I
thought he was awesome I thought he had
a great story he actually had a lot of
plot row relevance he was far and away
the most I reckon he was the most
interesting member and had um really the
only hero moment really tough awesome
hero moment yeah that was my favorite
part of the conflict and internal
conflict and turmoil and redemption as
well but yeah it makes for a really nice
up-and-down for a character yeah
unfortunately the slight problem in El
Diablo is that he is far and away more
powerful than the rest of them combined
which does make you wonder if they were
gonna have this squad to take out
superhuman threats they probably could
have just brought LDL I mean that ties
into the hole he's the most powerful but
he's really reluctant to use his powers
things like that is that is well thought
ground yeah katana I wanted to see so
much more of katana yes like they touch
on the stuff that makes the character
really cool like the soultaker sword and
like a dead husband and she just never
really but yeah that was just kind of
lie any thing yeah footnotes like
checkbox yes like yep mentioned the
soul-sword like here's her backstory
imagine in a couple of minutes he's her
in japan killing some dudes yeah that's
it and she's here now yeah yeah and
finally a good friend slipknot who
doesn't even get so because there's so
many characters it does the title card
thing was like here's their name and
he's cool facts about them yes yeah like
every ensemble movie ever does now
but a slipknot doesn't even get one and
he dies after like five minutes oh is
that I didn't even know who the hell
yeah exactly he was gotten rid of as
soon as you thought the whole point of
that was to be like oh look they can die
the government do have a parole and they
can explode them with you oh yeah oh
yeah that's like receptive Slipknot was
control collar so if they disobey orders
their heads explode yeah which whatever
um but they never even tease the idea
that slip knot is meant to be like a
full suicide squad member yeah it's just
like there were no stakes there we did
ya care at all yeah and on those title
cards I felt like that was a very cheap
way for them to shoehorn in a lot of
backstory which was my hair there was no
sort of all yeah exploration in between
the characters say from them interacting
and sort of learning about each other
and finally we've already touched on
this a little bit but Batman I think
like the whole thing with like suicide
squad being like a motley crew of like
bad guys think you're supposed to think
I like kind of fun and interesting it
would have been cool for Batman to have
a bigger role yes oh there was more of a
to and fro and more of a threat that
felt more like oh look a good guy threat
yeah because it was a bad guy this he
would have been made as such a more
impactful antagonist you know yeah yeah
the Enchantress a plotline kind of
wasn't really developed also you should
develop destroy the world that's what
someone says it's um what she's trying
to take over the world wait a minute
walk ins in the world like to what end I
don't they didn't really explore because
they were like weird old Aztec demon
things yeah but it's Oh No scooby-doo
episode if it's just like um there was
no looming threat it was just a point to
walk to yeah I will say I was expecting
something much smaller in scale which I
either feel like is a problem with most
of what days he's doing now everything
is like world-threatening but what I
really likes I watched probably around
this time last year was the Animated
Feature assault on Arkham which was
again The Suicide Squad and it was a
really tight they need to like break
into one place and get one thing and
Batman's kind of woven very well through
the story that's cool and it's just
really focused and still manages to
introduce the entire squad yeah
it's interesting and asking choconut oh
there you go it sort of reminds me of
like the second Avengers maybe like when
they have they have that cute moment
when they're all together and they're
trying to pick up Thor's hammer that is
when like in ensembles particularly
superhero ensembles I think are so good
when they're a cab my off each other
like that was what almost a dozen movies
deep into a connected universe I had my
need to care about those characters but
I think it's just like cuz these guys
barely even spoke they had like a couple
of scenes there was a scene in a bar
that they finally actually got to have
some conversations and judge each
other's past and that was one of the
more interesting scenes in the movie and
they were rare yeah definitely I think
based on the trailer was actually cut
quite short because it was [ __ ] in the
trailer that weren't in that bar scene
in the movie yes I did that interesting
yeah for a car this big they really
should have spent more time having them
interact and explore and see you lose
character moments because you know just
from the outside they are all very
relatively bland super we're gonna do a
lot of [ __ ] for that but you know it's a
guy who shoots well he's a guy who
throws a thing well a couple of strong
guys and a guy makes file I think you
know comparing it's a Guardians where
they were like maybe four or five very
distinct powerful beings all sides yeah
I'm gonna be here cool mix tapes so
whatever that there was no tracks they
really had to work hard to make each
personality shine do that well I think
we should always also if we're just
going through characters talk about
Amanda Waller yes because she's a
massive massive part of the Suicide
Squad and she's always been kind of more
morally ambiguous than this movie would
have you believe she is just straight up
a bad guy um down to like the control
collars to her just shooting people
who've been working with her because you
needed more proof that she was a bad guy
yeah like she's meant to be hard line
but not outright villainous yeah and I
don't think she was well treated in this
like what are you guys kind of think I
mean I didn't know about her beforehand
but she seemed like a [ __ ] yeah Shia I
just despise her yeah I could tell I
thought she would come off as more of a
bureaucrat to begin with but yeah
there's a twist that really makes you
hate her it's yeah what saying no but
yeah she's
anything else on the plot they want to
bring up the after main credits sequence
yes ok but not new I guess like the only
tease any there was no real surprise
there yeah fine it was there yeah also
like this it no I can't really go into
this without spoiling major plot details
but like so the whole control mechanism
for Enchantress enchantress is that
Amanda Waller has like her heart next to
a bomb right just just crush the heart
which is what look at ya you can take
her out very easily but you refuse to
you know yeah yeah there were lots of
things that felt like they didn't really
make any sense like at the very end ok
this is a spoiler at the end um you know
they big enchantress is the big bad
basically big bad witch and she gives
like Suicide Squad basically a chance to
be like hey you're all facing massive
prison sentences do you want to just
come with me and we can like take over
the world and whatever and then they are
like friendship is magic and it's like
no like these are there's no reason
there's calculus with Ali like a cover
they wouldn't like it's that it felt a
little like it happened that way because
it was a movie and I had to I guess
that's where it differs from like comic
and other like animated incarnation to
these characters as well because they
have history outside of this one movie
together and as villains and you don't
really get any of that interplay here
because they're just appearing for the
first time in this sport okay so why
would they know each other basic yeah
all right what do we like what do we
like about suicides good I think I like
I said before I felt like it kept
approaching cool moments like this is
what I keep saying about this movie is
that I kept feeling like it was getting
ready to go like it like I felt like any
moment it was gonna gear up it was gonna
have like one of these songs was gonna
kick into a really cool moment and there
were bits and pieces i really liked
there were battles where I was like oh
jeez like I can't believe that happened
or that was like [ __ ] awesome but it
was it was a smattering of moments
instead of like like a swell and and a
satisfying conclusion it was just like
lit
old bits that were fun there was like no
rising tension and pay off it was just
lots of little moments trans yeah that's
it there were there were cool moments
like yeah it was in the most of the cool
moments were in the trailer but I'm the
bit where Captain Boomerang is just
cracking the tinny behind the car that's
right it's like little nods to hey these
are like people doing funny things
that's right that they don't really own
in the movie they just show you them
that's right yes they definitely do the
same as the way the songs are thrown in
yeah thanks Joe in these much like the
film's marketing material it's a collage
a little bits and pieces that ya don't
really amount to a nice hole I mean
Batman was cool that man was definitely
very cool i did enjoy him and I don't
like Batman very much as a hero yeah he
was good what now finally what were your
sort of biggest criticisms what's your
biggest take away when you walked out of
the theater last night what did you
think I think the biggest issue with it
is just really really shoddy pacing yeah
that's the first thing I said like
there's lots of little scenes that in
isolation in different movies will be
really good and really well served but
they're just strung together so you
never get a sense of flow you never get
attached to the characters it's just
stuff happens and you don't get ya
surgery it feels like the second or
third iteration of like a Marvel or DC
movie where it's just like they're just
doing stuff with the characters and some
bits are cool and some bits are slow and
it's just like it didn't feel like
kicking off yeah like a brand new
franchise with a bunch of what could be
quite interesting characters with you
know an impressive cast they have the
cast for it yeah um I'm not sure they
had the plot yeah yeah to me it felt it
it really did feel like this is DC's
guardians of the galaxy but when a cramp
way too many things into it and like it
make everything way too heavy-handed and
just the style really grated me yes so
how would you fix it how would I fix it
yeah cut half the squad introduce them
slowly maybe a squad of three or four
and may make the stakes much lower yeah
and I have sort of more quiet moments in
between them it's interesting because
what was so successful about the
trailers was how tight they were like
there was so yeah
they were perfectly delivered and like
on bait like they hit every bait like
kanchan why cuz I just lifted stuff
directly yeah but the movie is the
opposite it like it feels off like it's
not in sync with itself felt like a
trailer yeah like it's just lots of
little cool bits bits that was it yeah I
think it honestly I don't regret seeing
it I'm still glad that I saw it I I
thought it was fun enough I thought it
was interesting I hope that with that it
further iterations they'll be able to
work on this stuff but I was just a
little letter yeah I would watch other
things with these characters in them um
but it feels like a not great first
attempt well that's all from us for more
on Suicide Squad you can check out our
both our written review and video review
on gamespot oh and also written review
on Cena yes
don't forget for the bad guys
you